inflation is still rising in America not
that you need a reminder and the newest
figures are raising serious concerns
about our economy researchers at Bank of
America now predict what they call a
mild recession beginning later this year
Nancy Chen has the inflation numbers
Nancy good morning Adriana good morning
to you the government's consumer price
index report showed the rate of
inflation in June surged 9.1 percent
over the same month last year a 41-year
high that means the average household is
now spending nearly 500 more a month
than in 2021. wages are up nearly five
percent but that is no match for the
nearly 10 percent inflation rate the
fact is most Americans are feeling the
pinch
Amanda Morrow expected the rent for her
Manhattan apartment to go up this year
but not by over 50 percent does it feel
like an eviction it does it does because
there's no way that we can afford to
stay here anymore she says the only way
out is for her and her husband to leave
the city there's nothing we could have
really done to prepare for that kind of
an increase it's happening all over the
neighborhood all over the city and
across the country rents Rose by nearly
six percent in June the highest
one-month jump in nearly 40 years
electricity is up more than 13 percent
food prices are also Sky High with
groceries costing families 12 percent
more than last year CBS News business
analyst Joe Schlessinger all those
categories eat up so much of a family's
budget that it just does not leave a lot
of extra for anyone to feel comfortable
in this kind of an economy in a
statement Wednesday President Biden
called the inflation numbers
unacceptably high but out of the figures
were out of date given the recent drop
in gas prices
a gallon of gasoline is down just over
40
afford the record five dollars a gallon
it reached in mid-june the pressure is
on for the Federal Reserve to get more
aggressive officials could again hike
interest rates three quarters of a point
later this month to cut down borrowing
and spending by consumers and businesses
but even that may come at a price the
FED May raise rates too much too quickly
which would slow down the price
increases but it could also push the
economy into a recession
and it's not just the U.S inflation has
spiked overseas as well in fact the U.S
dollar and the Euro are equal for the
first time in two decades a shift while
good for U.S importers is bad for
exporters Tony a mild recession it's not
too mild if you're the one who lost
their job Nancy thank you very much